[Music]
dr. Nam
more than 13 million people come here
every year yet only a fraction of them
knows that these vaulted ceilings howls
one of the most precious and closely
guarded relics and all Christendom the
crown of bones I've been granted special
access to see the ground up close and
learn more about what the faithful see
in this sacred object father Denis
dutifully is one of its curators this
this is it this is it this is very rare
to show it like that
it's been the prized possession of the
Catholic Church in France for almost 800
years of course it fits the genuine
article in far older than that the crown
which is made of reeds of herbs of weeds
and that put it in this circle of gas
actually with gold around there and they
added a few gold wires to maintain it or
a babe they make actual reeds or held
together now with little gold wire yes
and then they put this gasping and they
sealed it is to preserve it from air
from pollution from contact but what we
call the crown of phones was actually
sort of an helmet of phones and so they
on this circle they made an helmet with
the phones and then they'd set it on the
head that was really horrible
the Gospels say that when Jesus was
carrying his cross with all Gotham from
soldiers mocked him as the King of the
Jews and placed a crown of thorns on his
head I have this question for you
friends that's a long way from Golgotha
yes that's a long story so Helen who was
a mother of the Emperor took it from
Jerusalem to Constantinople in the
fourth century the Roman Emperor
Constantine's mother had converted to
Christianity and claimed the crown as a
key symbol of Jesus was suffering on the
cross and then nearly 1,000 years the
crown stayed in Constantinople then
there was the war but the Emperor had no
money to pay the army so to get the
money for his army he put the crown in
loan in Venice
he alone the crown and when the King of
France learned that King Louis say it's
a shame so I give the money for the army
and I get the crown in a safe place
that's France okay so in twelve hundred
and thirty-nine it arrived in France
uh-huh and when king louis welcomed this
crown in paris he went out of the city
with bare feet on your shirt on him and
he said well i've the most powerful King
on earth but I'm nothing in comparison
to the true king micronus of God but his
crown is a true one it was made of forms
so it was very very moving from this man
who was the most powerful on earth at
the time you know and the money he gave
was one full year of France budgets you
can imagine it was tremendous right
apparent money
so the amount was paid probably opened
the doorway for a lot of fake stuff well
you can never be sure 100%
they are the true ones but in this case
it was analyzed a little bit a few years
ago so we are certain
that is the actual chrome which was
shown to Helen so if there is one in the
world it's this one I know you said that
if there is a crown of thorns this is it
yes well if it really touched Christ of
course it is obvious but even if it's
not the true one it's a way of
remembering okay
he really was on earth he was a true man
it could bear that it could have that on
his very head and this is no story this
is no a tale or a symbol or an
abstraction this is history
this is concrete we can touch it you
know
[Music]
today is the first Friday of the month
when the crown is put on public display
people from all over the world come to
attend Mass and get close to the relic
[Music]
by so doing they believe they are
getting closer to Jesus
people come there with the surfing's
with the hopes and they come to this
crown they come to Christ actually okay
okay
you suffered you hoped
I suffer I hope I want to join with you
so that's very very deep simple in a way
but very very moving
[Music]
holy relics or symbols of the divine
here on earth as us they can and do fall
under the control of people who would
use them for earthly power but for those
who are seeking spiritual strength
relics actors become weakened faith that
guide them through the distractions of
this mortal realm to a more direct
connection with God
[Music]